I want to call this uh meeting of the
house rules committee to order and
our single thing on our menu right now
is to allow weight Drafting and
introduction bill so representative Roy
representative Mo Muse you want to come
us good morning thank you for convening
and being willing to hear us this
morning um I'll start and I'll turn it
over to representative
Muse after the news of the um tragic
killing of Chief ha as the chair of the
criminal justice committee I looked into
it to see what if anything was necessary
that we could do and kind of see what
the current state of the law was um and
the current state of the law in New
Hampshire is similar to the federal law
in that if you are involuntarily
committed you are barred from owning
Firearms or from purchasing fire
Firearms the problem we discovered is
that while New Hampshire recognizes that
there is no mechanism in current law for
that report to happen in that person's
name to be entered into the Nick system
so there's a gap between our recognizing
it and it actually
happening representative Muse and I have
I believe got elected at the same time
we've been here this is our third term I
like to consider myself one of the stous
defendant of the Second Amendment and
when I thought about introducing this
legislation I thought to make sure that
we do this correctly and get everyone's
Buy in the first name that popped in my
head was representative Muse who's been
one of the strong strongest advocates
for gun
control for us to be together here today
tells you something that we think that
this is serious and we think it needs to
be addressed now and I'll turn it over
to representative
Muse
there are over 40 other states uh in
this country that actually send uh
Mental Health Data reporting data uh to
the next system uh so we're not we would
not be outliers by sending data to the
system there are uh I think there are
some pretty compelling reasons uh to do
this and one of the most compelling
reasons uh was what likely happened uh a
couple of weeks ago at New Hampshire
hospital um we're in a situation right
now where where people who
basically um may not be in control uh of
themselves who may have severe mental
illness are in a position where they can
walk into a gun store and and buy a
firearm um and I think one of the things
that we have consistently recognized is
while all of us have a right to uh you
know to own a firearm under the
Constitution um I don't think anybody
body wants a firearm in the hands of
somebody um who is subject to things
like um acts of
psychosis uh and who uh is literally not
in control of themselves uh and and I
think that's the thing that we are we're
really trying to stop
um one of the things I I do want to say
is that there is a tremendous amount to
unpack with legislation like this one of
the things that we want to make sure of
uh is that if we have a Prohibition on
weapons for people with certain mental
health conditions that if those people
get better uh they have a way to retain
their right to uh to to own weapons
again so there's a way uh to uh to
reverse uh this process when people get
better there are some complexities
though uh there are people who are on uh
medication on an ongoing basis for
psychotic episodes who if they go off
their medication
may not be people that we want to
possess weapons so there are going to be
issues like that that we need to look
into so to help us work through these
issues I I think we're not only going to
be in touch with uh Folks at the
Attorney General's office but we've also
involved um uh Holly Stevens uh and
Susan Sterns from Nami uh to help make
sure that whatever we do uh we don't
wind up uh further uh stigmatizing uh
people with mental health conditions so
one of the things that we are are going
to try to do in the legislation that we
submit is to make sure that we properly
balance the public safety concerns which
right now are out of balance um with the
concern that we not only don't
stigmatize uh people with mental health
conditions but also people who may need
treatment um we don't want to
necessarily provide a huge dis incentive
for them to refuse treatment because
they think their their guns may be taken
away from them so again there a lot of
issues to work through a lot of issues
to unpack uh but we we really are hoping
uh that we'll get your support to file
uh this legislation
today if I could just add um quickly um
I'm particularly cognizant of the fact
that we have been at War for decades and
as part of that we have thousands of
veterans um who who have PTSD and who
need and seek routinely um mental health
treatment and I would want to do nothing
that would discourage them from getting
the help they need nor would I want to
punish them um with the greatest of
tragic ironies by taking their rights
away because they went to defend ours so
we're going to be very diligent and very
careful and crafting this legislation um
as representative you said so that no
one is punished for seeking the help
that they need while at the same time
balancing the need of the public to be
safe to ensure that Firearms do not end
up in the hands of people who definitely
do not have them and um I've recruited
um representative Stone who's all going
to also going to co-sponsor the bill and
he's already working on the restoration
of Rights process which is indeed
complicated the um any program you
devise to get the restoration of Rights
has to meet the criteria from the US
Department of Justice and the ATF and
you actually have to get them to sign
sign off on it before you can do it
otherwise it will be meaningless in
other words you could say someone has
their rights back but when they go to
buy a gun they'll still be on the list
because the ATF did not approve the
program so we have to make sure that we
it meets those criteria so with that I
we would appreciate your your allowing
us to do this as you know this was
unforeseen we could not have thought of
this and done this in time to do it
according to house rules thank you
questions
Denis Smith thank you Mr chair well
before discussion first I'd like to move
to approve the request
second open for further discussion you
have any questions or you just makeing
go
ahead and uh and thank you Mr chair for
allowing this to go beyond the usual
scope of why the drafting is late I
think we all recognize that um do you
representative Roy believe that the
proposal you're putting puts enough
respect and focus on the due process
rights of the affected
individuals thank you I do and and while
it's difficult because I have no
legislation in front of me obviously
because OS won't draft it until you say
they can um but what we are envisioning
um purely follows the federal law the
Federal Law requires if you are
involuntarily committed that means not
because you went on your own to get help
but because you refused to get help or
you were unable to get it on yourself a
judge commits you involuntarily part of
that process in the Hampshire law is
adversarial you are entitled to a lawyer
um if you cannot afford one one will be
appointed to you so that the due process
is definitely involved um the person has
a has a right to challenge this before
it happens they're allowed to call
witnesses they're allowed to speak in
their own defense um only after that
process is done and the judge enters an
order of involuntary commitment would
the person be added to the list and
likewise on the other end due process is
also involved in getting their rights
restored where they go to a judge and
they present evidence why they no longer
should be on that
list thank youat
shli thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
uh first of all I commend you both on
the desire to introduce this legislation
and secondly for the spirit of
bipartisanship that you're showing it's
so important um I just want to ask do
you look forward to getting sponsors
from the Senate from both parties to
would join you on the bill thank you
actually I have already spoken to uh
Senator Whitley who is going to
co-sponsor it and so is Senator abis
thank
questions
okay we need a roll call am I correct
the motion is to approve the late
drafting chairman Packard yes Vice
chairman sh yes representative Smith yes
representative
Koval yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Weber yes representative
evil yes motion is adopted 9 to
zero there any other business to come
if not I just wish to thank you all
again for your time and your votes we
have a motion to adjourn so move it's
returned